hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video i'm going to be going over some of
my thoughts and why i think the tokyo
revenge's manga won't have a
so-called happy ending i've seen a few
people asking for more tokyo avengers
videos in the comments which is
absolutely awesome and i'm extremely
keen to fulfill all of your requests but
in return i would like to offer a trade
for more tokyo revenge's content and
theories i ask that you will hit that
subscribe button and leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with
pushing my content to new people and
also lets me know you're currently
enjoying what i create but enough of
that
let's get into the video so i honestly
feel like the
tokyo avengers bontine arc isn't going
to end with the so called happy ending
everyone wants to see like myself
included it easily could take this path
of ending with takamichi saving mikey
and the entire tomen gang
all surviving along with them succeeding
in life just like we've seen in the
current timeline
bar mikey and takamichi obviously as
personally i'd imagine they both did
having fallen to the ground after he
leaped back to
where he is now in the story but yeah
ending the story that way just doesn't
feel right to me for some kind of reason
as much as i want this happy ending i
can't see the story being an absolutely
amazing series that captures the hearts
and minds of people without some kind of
i guess sad ending i personally want to
see tokyo avengers go down as the best
delinquent manga of its time
and like i already think it is but i
need this final arc to cement there and
show me that i'm not wrong
recently i've come to realize more than
anything that the way someone ends a
series can either totally ruin
everything that they may have built up
with
years of hard work and an amazing
storyline but if you can't seem to wrap
it up in a way that appeases the
majority of the masses then you're going
to be hit with a flood of messages and
even death threats
which i do not support by any means like
never go out of your way to attack a
mangaka directors editors and anyone
else who takes part in the process of
creating a series that you enjoy
but you can't deny that this thought of
a subpar ending must put an overwhelming
pressure on the creators of series
as we've obviously seen in the past with
attack and titan and game of thrones
so i'm hoping that the creator of tokyo
avengers ken waiku
can wrap up the series perfectly how can
i see him doing this in creating an
ending that cements itself in manga
history
is by having our crybaby hero takamichi
die while saving mikey just like he has
done in chapter 204
when he catches mikey mid-ear as he is
falling to his death
after trying to end it all i think that
to save mikey there needs to be
something so profound that stops him
and his apparent dark urges from
enveloping him i can see this bontine
arc taking the route of takamichi having
to create a new gang of delinquents most
likely the revival of the black dragons
i feel like it's going to happen this
way because we know that takamichi
resembles mikey's brother in the same
manner that yeah he isn't strong
physically but mentally he is stronger
than anyone else we've met in this
series so far
except for maybe kasaki who was just a
genius and wasn't exactly mentally
stronger just extremely smart and only
lost because of a truck and the fact
that takamichi can change the future
so yeah i see takamichi fully taking
this brother-like role for mikey which
probably results in something like the
battle at the church in the black
dragons arc i imagine takamichi and a
few others possibly the entire tomen
group
show up to stop a fight between mikey's
new group the kanto imaging gang
and probably the torano south who i see
becoming the other big threat which
somehow results in takamichi dying
but not like just how draken almost died
when he was stabbed and left to the side
of the battle
i see it being something like our man
bhaji's death where to make maki realize
things and to snap him out of this haze
he might be in and to stay true to what
mahi asked him 10 years in the future
to save him takamichi all beaten up and
bruised will stab himself
after doing absolutely everything that
he can to try and stop mikey and make
him realize things i've just got this
feeling that takamichi doing
something so brazen after pouring his
soul out to mikey would make him realize
he is about to lose another brother of
his that he has tried his best to push
away
hoping that it would result in
everyone's safety realising his plan is
collapsing he would crawl out of the
sphere of darkness and try to rush
takamichi to the hospital or ride in the
ambulance with him there if one is
called
i feel like if he was to die it would be
any hospital beard with hina on his side
and mikey and all the other members of
tomon draken
matsuya shifuyu etc surrounding him
possibly even watakamichi seeing baji
holding out his hand welcoming takamichi
to the afterlife and a beautiful final
panel
but yeah obviously i don't have a clue
on how the series is exactly going to
end but i had a lot of fun with
theorizing and just rereading some of
this
amazing series that tokyo avengers is if
you have enjoyed the video
and have some theories of your own then
be sure to drop a comment down below
with what you expect to happen
also if you are new out here and want to
see more tokyo revenge's content then
hit that subscribe button and be on the
lookout for weekly spoilers and review
videos for tokyo revenges
plus if you do enjoy my content feel
free to hit that like button as it
really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my content to the masses
but anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all
in a bit bye
[Music]
you